Well,
there are unusual in the sense that
statistically it's unusual could say
it's just,
it's a statistical at Ollie's
statistical fluke.
There's no reason to think that
earthquakes are occurring any more
frequently now than they had then they
occurred last year or 10 years ago,
or 10 years into the future.
There's no reason to believe that,
and it has nothing to do with global
warming.
Believe me,
that's a question that we often get.
Well,
one of the things we've learned
seismologists is that earthquakes that
occurred anytime at any place,
in fact,
they don't even have to occur at plate
boundaries for that matter.
But that's,
that's a whole other topic.
Uh,
but along some of the major plate
boundaries,
like,
uh,
that Pacific northwest,
we have evidence of pastor earthquakes.
And that's actually isn't,
it's an interesting thing.
Obviously we didn't have instruments
going back more than about a hundred
years or so.
So we don't have an instrumental record,
but we have a record from a newspaper,
old newspapers,
for example.
We have a record from some old mission
records,
particularly in California,
Spanish mission records and elsewhere
throughout the western hemisphere.
Uh,
we have very long,
uh,
historical records in China and Japan
and,
and in parts of Asia where people have
been writing things down for quite a few
centuries.
Uh,
but in some places we simply don't have
that written record and we have to rely
again on proxies.
Um,
there are a couple of things we can do
in a place like a California or Seattle,
the state,
California first.
Uh,
one thing we can do when we have a fault
like the San Andreas is to actually dig
a trench across that fault.
And when we trench across false like
that,
and you do that,
trenching it at different places,
you can actually see in the disturbed
soil the record of pastor earthquakes,
it may occur every hundred and 50 or 200
or three or 400 years,
uh,
but with very good carbon dating or
other geological techniques,
uh,
we can get a good sense of what that
history is.
And by doing that trenching at various
places along the fault,
we can even get a,
an estimate of the,
of the size of the rupture,
which gives us a way to calculate the
magnitude that then allows us to
calculate the repeat intervals safe for
these very large earthquakes in Seattle,
or I should say more generally off the
coast of British Columbia,
Washington and Oregon going down into
northern California.
That's a different kind of a plate
boundary.
It's what we call a subduction zone.
It's a convergent boundary.
It creates the cascades and the
volcanoes,
uh,
so we can't trench it.
Um,
but what we can do is look at the
history of uplift on the coast because
every time an earthquake occurs,
uh,
the upper plate,
which is basically the coast of
Washington and Oregon and northern
California gets bumped up a little bit.
And by looking at the sediment Terry
record,
actually sometimes it can go down as
well,
but you know,
looking the sediment Terry record,
uh,
looking at the way,
say even trees or drowned by encroaching
water or lifted above the water table or
so on.
A,
you can get a sense of the history,
uh,
people who look at things like tree
rings or the history of corals
[inaudible] corals up there now.
But if we go elsewhere around the world,
we see that,
uh,
these are all proxies for past big
earthquakes.
There's another proxy which,
um,
in particular for the Pacific Northwest
Works and that is,
uh,
earthquakes along that boundary have a
tendency to generate.
It's an army and when it's an Ami,
propagates mu or moves across the
Pacific Ocean,
particularly a big one,
when it hits islands,
uh,
on the other side of the Pacific,
you get what's called tsunami deposits.
It's a,
it's a very turbulent phenomena,
brings up pebbles and rocks and disturbs
the beaches and,
uh,
you can detect some of those.
Um,
but in particularly for the,
for the particular case of the Pacific
northwest,
uh,
around 1700,
actually in 1700 a tsunami was
generated.
It was recorded in Japan.
And by looking at the,
uh,
tsunami records in Japan,
both the historical record and the
actual geologic record of that tsunami
modelers have been able to kind of back
project that go backwards across the
Pacific show that the source of that
tsunami was in fact the Pacific
northwest,
and get a good date 1700,
uh,
for that event.
That event looks like to be about a
magnitude nine,
nine and a half.
That's bigger than what we had in Chile
last,
uh,
just a few weeks ago.
Uh,
and it's about as big as the biggest
earthquake we've recorded
instrumentally.
So now that we know that that boundary
can support a monstrous earthquake,
magnitude nine,
we can go about the job of measuring the
Wa,
how fast the plates are converging,
making some assumptions about how stress
is building up and come up with some
sense of what the repeat interval might
be for that earthquake.
And,
uh,
sad to say we're pretty close to the
repeat interval for that earthquake.
So that's a forecast.
It's not a prediction,
it's a forecast.
And thankfully,
at least in the United States,
going back a decade or more,
uh,
seattle and Oregon had been well aware
of the potential for that earthquake,
and they're taking the appropriate
steps.
One would say,
to try to mitigate the potential damage.